johnson et kevin hart qui était de
passage à paris pour la promotion du
film c'est de manger toute blinde
johnson qu'un monstre physiquement et du
cinéma d'action aux etats unis c'est une
vraie star là bas ils ont absolument
voulu vous rencontrer du coup vous
aurait profité que les interviewés et ça
donne évidemment les images
exceptionnelles comme les filets alors
regardez la première partie c'est vrai
j'ai rencontré the rock et kevin hart
ces deux immenses stars regarde et
zapper tout signe ou de rock dans
l'autre de rock mon ami je mange semoule
le mec nous avons c'est ça le beau but
kevin fans inquiets franchement merci
pour les tenues franchement vous êtes
magnifique et 2,6 g j'ai adoré fini le 2
exceptionnel vous êtes passé aux jeux
vidéo alors moi je suis une petite
émission
donc j'ai vais pas dans le budget
j'avais pas le budget pour 2010 j'avais
pas le budget pour faire un jeu vidéo
donc j'ai fait avec des cartes donc les
règles du jeu sont simples il faut que
vous répondiez à toutes les questions
vous pouvez des victoires sinon vous
devez rester avec moi nous restons dans
votre vie je vous laisserai plus jamais
à toul et alors
c'est vrai que il était très sympathique
et ils ont joué le jeu et ils ont joué
le jeu des défis regardez franchement il
était top les nausées mais quand ils
sont sympas 48 ans très très sympa et
les deux sont hyper sympa français lui
l'ancien champion de catch bien sûr
c'est pas kevin est excellent kevin
c'est une immense star c'est une des
plus grandes stars américaines kevin
hart regarde sais pas encore
[Rires]
[Musique]
dwan et phil drift
c'est pas bien c'est que c'est guy
delage basket basket le maillot l'équipe
de france
[Applaudissements]
je mange dix ans aujourd'hui le film est
excellent et les deux l'a vu quand ils
sont sympas ça nous change de charlize
theron non plus on est grand et briand
lyon dessin c'est vrai kevin hart c et
les doutes façon 106 103 millions de
followers et 83 millions de followers
c'est l'acteur le mieux payé du monde
dwayne johnson the rock non jean pellez
0,6 mais voilà les petits mots sur
instable et bat référé pendant il ya pas
eu d'effets physiques entre entre vous
et lui alors je vous le dis mais il n'a
pas voulu et les assurances voilà je
vous le dis